well there's still a very acute um
shortage of oxygen it seems across
india certainly one of the hospitals
that we went to yesterday
was telling us how they go hour to hour
really and they were
trying to get through the next six hours
and this morning they put out yet
another red flag
warning about the shortage of oxygen
these people here have set up their own
impromptu very small but just trying to
do their bit
they traveled around the state they went
500 kilometers away to try to source
oxygen which they bought in
as many cylinders as they could it was
only about a dozen or so
and people have been camping out here
under the trees
just to get access to that oxygen many
of them
as we've been finding in many of these
places and and the number of the
hospitals that we've visited have been
turned away
from hospitals even the government
hospitals the private hospitals
because they too are running short on
oxygen
and clearly that's put everyone in a
very high
state of distress delhi and
india has posted yet more record global
record highs in the number of
coronavirus cases it dipped slightly
today
on the sixth day but it's still a global
record high in the spike of
of cases uh and international aid is
finally beginning to arrive the british
aid arrived this morning vital medical
supplies along with i understand about
20
oxygen ventilators well that's
grasped with great gratitude from the
people of india but clearly it's not
going to go
very far when you just have a quick look
here at just
this small little um patch under trees
and how many people
are actually needing oxygen one woman
told us she'd been here
for two days already when clearly she
should probably be
in a hospital well one of the people who
are running it is ishan
singh let's try and have a quick quick
word with him ishan
you're live on on sky news tell me how
critical is the situation here and
how much trouble have you had in finding
oxygen
see if i talk about the ground situation
over here
we have patients who are waiting here
for two days they're not finding any
hospital
they just wanted oxygen because their
doctor has advice they have
they're on high antibiotics so that lady
over there if you see
she is here with our sons they rented a
car and they came here
two days back and still they cannot find
any
hospital they cannot find any bed they
are still here because their doctor
is advised if we see over there there's
a man behind me
he came here three days back he was fine
he went back again he came back
so his oxygen is going up and down
there's no medical facility proper
facility
yes and what do you think as as a as an
indian of this state of affairs when
it's reduced to
charities like yourself trying to
provide people with air
what do you think make of that as a as
an indian
actually it's not just about an indian
eye being a sikh i can come from a sikh
religion
so we have always given the service to
people
starting from guru nanak dev ji our
first guru starting way back in 1469
so he gave free food to hungry people
and it started from there and when guru
gobind sings
our tenth guru he was in wars
i don't mean to interrupt you i totally
understand the the history lesson i just
wanted to get a sense
as a as indians how desperate you're
feeling
um clearly the sikhs have got a long
history in helping people but just a a a
global view on how
desperate you're feeling the rest of the
world is looking at you
and seeing that you've got the global
record hides in coronavirus cases and
you're running out of basic things like
oxygen
actually the thing is over here we don't
see as a anyone is a stranger we all are
a family
this lady over here i call her as my
mother as my sister and everything
this part this old man who here i call
him as my grandfather or father
so i when i see my family over here
struggling for oxygen strongly for
medicines
i have to come here and i have to serve
my people that that's what we feel
and our charity called him foundation we
started
10 years back in and in the lockdown
last year we were on the ground we were
delivering food and everything well
you're doing a great job thank you very
much
ishan singh from the heckman foundation
one of many who are set up to try and
help
ordinary people because it doesn't
matter where you are throughout india
there seems to be
a real acute shortage of oxygen and that
is clearly having an impact on
on getting people better and and a lot
of people very suspicious about the
numbers and questioning whether they're
absolutely accurate they could be a lot
worse